[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages
in the next half hour or so uh we'll
take a look at the headlines with the
sun's political editor harry cole
and the political editor of the daily
mirror pippa craig great to see both of
you
so as ever at the front pages let's take
a look scotland's billy gilmore
along with england's mason mount and ben
chilwell
all uh question marks now for the euros
after billy gilmore tested positive
for covid scott to be joking the sun
reports that england's camp has been
thrown into chaos due to the
two stars having to self-isolate
don't expect restriction free travel
abroad until next year says the prime
minister which is the lead for the eye
but the times reporting that
holidaymakers who have had both kova
jabs
could enjoy quarantine free travel
from august the guardian leads on the
education committee's report into white
working-class pupils
who have been let down by decades of
neglect in the english
schooling system according to a report
by mps
the lord chief justice has told the
telegraph that some
trials could take place with juries
smaller than 12.
armen lashed the front runner to replace
angela merkel as germany's next
chancellor
has warned of the dangers that china
poses for the west
as anger for campaigners after a meeting
between the prime minister
the health secretary and the chancellor
about whether to introduce a cap
on care costs was cancelled
so harry cole and pippa create are here
bit of a mixed bag of front pages has to
be said but let's dive straight in with
the
uh what happens to the euros um pippa
obviously great disappointment for
scotland a massive game
tomorrow night um but what does it mean
in terms of the championship indeed that
the two teams who met last friday
well yes you're absolutely right as a
scottish fan i was very impressed by
billy gilmore's
man of the match obviously very well
deserved after his first scotland
start um against england he obviously is
an impressive young player
but you know i'm i'm an optimist our
team has got a lot of other great
players and i
i'm sure that we will obviously put our
heart into it when it when it comes to
the croatian match
it has obviously had uh the match has
had quite a fallout hasn't it because
billy gilmore's tested positive and it
was those very striking pictures at the
end of the match
of him embracing his chelsea teammates
mason mountain ben chilwell
as they left the pitch and understand
that they also stood around in the
tunnel afterwards and had a chat and
we're in close book 70s to each other
a lot of people are tonight saying well
hang on a sec these two
players these english players are having
self-isolating could potentially miss
england's big match tomorrow while the
rest of the scottish squad seem to be
okay and that's because of
the uefa protocol that playing on the
pitch
is not regarded as closed contract as
opposed contacts under the coverage
rules
whereas embracing someone and standing
face to face and talking with them
is now what the scotland squad upped off
that match
uh which obviously was a good result of
scotland to draw in the dressing room
and
of course those pictures of steve clark
the manager also embracing
billy gilmore you know it does
definitely raise these questions about
whether the rest of the team who have
all tested positive
sorry before that's the negative i
should say um uh
whether they you know you know whether
it's okay for them to be playing while
the two england players who have also
tested negative
have to wait longer for their results um
it definitely raises questions for fans
and a lot of disappointment on both
sides i
think tonight yeah absolutely i mean
there was a lot of hugging after that
game
wasn't there uh billy gilmore was seen
face to face with the
uh with the scotland manager a video
posted and then deleted showed him
playing table tennis
back at the base with andy robertson i
mean there are so many questions should
you wait for me saying
don't hug or shake hands with t with the
opposition after a game
um i mean you know where do you start
with the questions this is this is posed
harry
well i'm fairly certain billy gilmore
wasn't the only scot to visit london
last week after the scenes we saw and
come back with a case of covid
um i suspect there's quite a few fans
who've picked it up as well
um after all those scenes in high park
and oxford street um
questions for yay for obviously mounting
you know this is exactly what
the tournament organizers didn't want to
happen but
sort of is inevitable if you are going
to host a uh try and host a major
international sporting event in the
middle of
a in the middle of a pandemic um uefa
obviously
currently tonight seem more occupied in
trying to get 2 500
of their sponsors and delegates into
london for the final
uh and the semi-finals without having to
quarantine with the threat of taking
away the matches from wembley
and moving them to hungary where there
are no travel restrictions uh currently
um if if we don't play ball on that but
look
it's a bit of a disaster one the good
news tonight um by luck of the draw the
way the other teams have fallen
even if england lose to the czech
republic which touchwood they won't
tomorrow night
we will qualify anyway for the for the
next round so
there's a bit of pressure off tonight
but this is a bit of a disaster
um they're keeping it very vague exactly
what's happening there gary southgate
put out a statement earlier saying the
team were
liaising with public health england over
mount and chill well whether
they will be i fall twice late i think
there'll probably be some form of fudge
where they'll have to take a series of
tests
they're all taking lateral flow tests at
the moment which are the the the type
that aren't as accurate
but a rapid very quickly done and turned
around in about 20 minutes
so i suspect with a pcr test or two they
might not have to isolate the full 14
days
but um it won't do a huge amount of help
towards those people that are saying
that
it's one one rule for the international
super elite and footballers
uh and another another rule for the uh
for the ordinary journey
yeah i mean it's it's leading your paper
as well isn't it it's got to be joking
but you're right it raises
that question to why can't you just
double jab every player in the
tournament
oh no you can't because you decided you
were going to do it on age and you can't
be seen to
not be jabbing teachers but you can be
to to have a bit of
sporting entertainment for people and
but also why can't they be tested hourly
um in order to be able to play oh oh no
you can't because the rest of us then
would want to be
in order to go somewhere so raises all
these questions which is currently
facing the government right now
is what do we get for our double
vaccination what do we get for all this
testing we're putting ourselves through
and and how do we get the economy going
again pippa doesn't it
yes absolutely but the government you
know
the english members of the government
may uh be regretting tomorrow night not
having to the key players if it
indeed comes to that um but i think they
would be
uh finding it a lot harder had they
decided to go ahead
with giving uh footballers preferential
treatment i mean gary seth lifegate of
course said that he
shouted down for suggesting that the
team should be
given both their jobs some time ago back
in the spring so that they would be
they would be better prepared for this
tournament um
and dealing with covid so it's um you
know
there's all these questions as we go
into the summer obviously we've had
uh where there's lots of uh work going
on there's
research studies going on at the moment
on thousands of people
pilot studies about whether individuals
can be
um will no longer have to have their 10
day quarantine if they come into close
contact with somebody that has
uh tested positively covered themselves
but they're not there yet
so currently double jabbing doesn't give
you any preferential treatment
and obviously the idea behind that is
that until everybody
has had the the double jab or at least
been offered the double jab
then they can't be seen to discriminate
against younger age groups or people
that whatever other reason haven't had
their covid vaccine yet um but it is a
tricky period a sticky period for the
government really
over the next um sort of eight weeks or
so until it reached a position where
everybody has been offered it
yes and there's the uh the times
quarantine rules uh will be dropped for
the fully jab
but it takes us to the summer holidays
after the story over the weekend that
double jab might mean no quarantine on
your return from an ambulance country
um which didn't sound so positive
listening to boris johnson today that's
the lead for the eye
it's inside your paper as well which
we'll come to in a second harry
so what i mean what what is going to
happen um we're expecting this review on
on traffic lights aren't we what
what's your best bet um
from speaking to um people in wyoming
today it feels like yes it is going to
happen
they are looking to reward double jab
people but once lots more people have
been double jab and it feels like once
again the goal posts have been moved
first of all it was let's let's jab the
the vulnerable let's drop the elderly
and then we'll unlock and then it was
let's double jab the
vulnerable and the elderly and then it's
let's double jab everyone
and you just think we're in this weird
limbo land where the
where the promised land has been it's
been here for for six months now you
know our vaccine roll out has been
world beating all year and still now we
are being beaten into the march so to
speak by our european neighbors who
despite having an inferior jab rollout
have decided to
unshackle a bit more and uh we're
looking tomorrow in the sun
at uh the effect of um of what that's
done to european mediterranean beach
resorts which have been flooded with
germans
and so um now as soon as we're able to
possibly look and consider the
possibility of a european break later on
in the summer
um everything's gonna be booked up um so
a bit of controversy there boris john's
under pressure to to do something to to
you know what is to
reap the world reap the rewards sorry of
our jab rollout
by giving people more freedom there's no
point in having this brilliant you know
brilliant success rate
unless we're actually going to be able
to capitalize on it and you know it's
all very well
saying oh well we're looking in august
but you know the summer
summer's broadly over by the end of
august when it's going to be so there's
a review next week there's a review at
the end of july
and i think a lot of people could be
scratching their heads and not just
scratching their heads start to
you know start to disregard the rules a
little bit take the rules into their own
hands once they've been vaccinated with
one or two doses
and start to think this is all just a
bit mad yeah just very quickly then
pippa
so far nearly 60 of uk adults have had
two doses
the idea is that 70 will do by july the
19th
but all those other people who aren't
what do they do do they sue the
government saying but what about us it's
not our fault i can't
travel you decided this jabs order i
mean does it make it very difficult for
the government to reward those who are
vaccinated
it does and i think the reality is is
that um it's going to be moving pretty
quickly so we're not going to get into
the
sort of the likelihood of people being
sued or the government being sued
but it will certainly create a lot of
unhappy travelers who uh or
people who would otherwise be traveling
um if they see that
perhaps their parents or older friends
are able to go abroad
and so i think that's unlikely to happen
really it's unlikely to a change to be
made
um until more people are vaccinated we
wait for that don't we uh keep up the
good work
the vaccinators and all the volunteers
and plenty more still to come on this
program dominic cummings launching
another
attack on the government we'll be
discussing that after the break
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the sun's
political editor harry cole
and the political editor of the daily
mirror pippa crea welcome back to both
of you
um harry let's go to the guardian a new
report just out by
mps suggesting that white working-class
children
are the most neglected but uh what's the
guardian had to say about this
uh guardian taken obviously are quite
guardian look at this uh look at this
one and complaining about the findings
of the report
um well immediately as as it drops so
the education select committee very
powerful committee in the commons
have this you know there's a big study
into uh
sort of which children are left behind
in the classroom and they find that
white boys are
um are are the most sort of uh
forgotten uh forgotten sort of
demographic of pupils now that's nothing
new we've we've read that report
many times that's been written by a
range of charities think tanks
mps reports what is interesting in this
report is actually they look at the idea
of white privilege
and this is sort of the term that's spat
out and fired across the
culture wars left right and center uh as
this is this sort of great burden that
everyone must
flagellate themselves about uh all the
time and they're actually saying well
actually you know that can have a real
effect
on our on on white pupils especially
those who are already vulnerable
already left behind and actually maybe
it's a sort of word we shouldn't be
throwing around especially from the left
so much because it's having an impact on
on pupils
now there's a cause of great brouhaha in
the committee the labour mps on the
committee
have all refused to sign up to it so um
uh
if you if they were trying to spark a
conversation about this issue which i
think they probably were
um they've done very well about it yes
indeed it's the idea that everything
said has an impact pippa
even if it's for the purposes of of of
raising equality
yeah i'd be surprised how much uh how
little i think actually the term white
privilege is actually used in schools
and i think it'd be wise to take the
culture wars out of this because it's
absolutely the case
that white working class children boys
in particular underperform at school
compared to some of their peers
so too do black caribbean children not
much difference between them when you
look at the poorest or on preschool
meals
the reality is is that more needs to be
done to tackle poverty
amongst children there's 4.3 million
children in this country living in
poverty
and that in addition to regional
disparity and focusing on
some of the restoring some of the
support that exists around
schools whether it's extended school day
or community groups youth clubs and so
on that has been so
decimated of the last 10 years youth
services cut by 70 percent in the last
decade there's almost a milli
a billion pounds sorry um decline in
um in support for exactly these children
that need it so badly and
if that helped bolster them and bolster
schools and they do better in the
classroom
and do better and ultimately go on to
higher education or jobs as a result